if you're in the mood for Orphan
assassins a single fighter against an
entire army or Jackie Chan getting
serious then it's time to check out
these underrated martial arts flicks if
you're a fan of Iko uice you probably
know him from The Raid franchise or
possibly American movies like Snake Eyes
in addition to those credits he also
starred in another fantastic Indonesian
movie that hasn't gotten nearly as much
attention as it deserves 2016's headshot
stars uice as a man who wakes up from a
coma and doesn't know who he is so he
gives himself the name Ishmael when his
past comes knocking it does so with
punches and kicks and Ishmael engages in
one brutal battle after another as he
pieces his Memories Back Together it's a
movie that definitely isn't for the
faint of heart as the fights and the
resulting injuries manage to be even
more wince inducing than those in the
raid
based on the Chinese comic Oriental
Heroes 2006's Dragon Tiger Gate is
director Wilson yip's second
collaboration with martial arts Legend
Donnie Yen this time around Yen plays
Dragon Wong one of the two children of
the founders of the titular martial arts
academy Dragon grew up on the wrong side
of the law while his half-brother tiger
Wong followed a more law-abiding path
fate brings the two strangers together
one night in a thrilling restaurant
battle when they finally realize who
they are to each other they team up in a
series of fights that often rely a
little too heavily on CG but are still
an absolute joy to watch
if you're a fan of the likes of John
Wick and kill Bill you surely appreciate
when a one-person Army mows down dozens
of foes and gleefully over-the-top
fashion when this technique was deployed
for the climactic battle in 2003's Azumi
it was still somewhat novel and the film
deserves a lot of credit for Paving the
way for what came after based on the
manga series of the same name Izumi is
about the titular young girl who is part
of a group of Orphans who were trained
to become assassins Izumi isn't just
tough for a girl she's one of the
toughest protagonists of 21st century
Martial Arts Cinema period this movie is
so beloved that it's been partly
credited for revitalizing the entire
genre in 2013 Keanu Reeves stepped
behind the camera for the first time
when he directed and starred in Man of
Tai Chi his love of the genre is evident
in every frame as he crafts what feels
very much like an old-school martial
arts picture interestingly enough Reeves
plays the main antagonist who owns a
shady security firm and oversees an
underground fighting ring he takes
notice of an impressive Tai Chi fighter
played by Tiger Chen tiger is definitely
the star of the show here he was
previously on the stunt team for the
Matrix and Kill Bill and he proves to be
just as compelling in front of the
camera how would you like to test how
good you are tiger
Jackie Chan is obviously a martial arts
Legend but he hasn't always been as
successful with his more serious efforts
case in point The Foreigner directed by
Martin Campbell it actually did get a
decent amount of Acclaim when it was
released in 2017 and therefore might not
seem befitting of a list of underrated
movies but it deserves more attention
than it's gotten with a Chan in his
early 60s impressing us with expertly
choreographed fights and impressive
stunts Chan plays Quan Nook Min a quiet
businessman driven to seek Vengeance
when his daughter is killed in a
terrorist attack the human drama takes
Center Stage here but when Chan does
fight he's undeniably thrilling more
than 50 years into his legendary career
what if your wife and daughter were
killed by bomb
I do everything in my power to get
Justice with Jackie Chan moving toward
more serious fare in the last few
decades martial arts comedy has suffered
without its biggest star so what better
way to inject some new life than to
remake one of the earliest Classics of
the sub-genre 1978's enter the fat
dragon the original satirized Bruce
Lee's Enter the Dragon and way of the
dragon and much of that spirit is a lot
more present in the remake than you
might think the new version also goes
its own way as it puts Donnie in in
Prosthetics that round out his face and
belly which isn't exactly the best
aspect of this movie issues with the fat
suit aside enter the fat dragon is a
whole lot of fun with the end proving
his comedic chops in spades
though it features plenty of talent
you'd be forgiven for not giving 2019's
Triple Threat a second look if you came
across it in The Bargain Bin thanks to
its generic title and cover art but
everyone is bringing their a game here
and that's really saying something the
plot is admittedly nothing special and
doesn't shy away from genre tropes but
that's not why you watch a movie like
this the fight scenes are incredible
especially when the likes of Tony Shaw
and Iko uis are involved at the same
time when you add Tiger Chen Scott
Atkins and Michael Jai White into the
mix it should be abundantly clear the
triple threat is a must-watch for any
martial arts fan also known as Zen
Warrior within 2008's chocolate is an
extremely unorthodox martial arts epic
young and wisma tanata plays Zen the
daughter of a Yakuza boss and his lover
Zen Zinn eventually learns that Zen has
autism which she channels into her
obsession with mimicking the moves of
the students at a Muay Thai School
combined with almost superhuman reflexes
Zen becomes the ideal person to rescue
her kidnapped mother from the clutches
of her gangster ex-boyfriend what ensues
are some of the most elaborately staged
and original fight scenes ever put to
film simply put this is an excellent
martial arts flick whose Stars should be
more famous worldwide
filmmaker and playwright David Mamet is
best known for talking dramatic works
like Glenn Gary Glenn Ross but he's also
made some detours into action one of the
most notable is 2008's red belt which
stars chuatel ejiofor as an accomplished
fighter named Mike Terry who shuns
commercialization of the martial arts
but Mike finds himself involved in the
film industry after saving the life of
famous action star Chet Frank played by
Tim Allen while the action might take a
backseat to the morality play red belt
still proves surprisingly competent as
it delivers some extremely satisfying
fisticuffs the
the warrior you think it's Noble no I
think it's correct 2009's ninja is
somewhat underrated though it did manage
to build up a fair amount of Buzz among
fans of the genre and did well enough to
Warrant the sequel but 2013's Ninja
shadow of a tear was largely ignored
upon release which is unfortunate since
it might actually be better than its
predecessor Scott Adkins returns as
Casey Bowman who was attempting to
settle down with his new wife after the
events of the previous film but when
she's murdered he embarks upon a quest
for Revenge the fights are incredible
and this movie is absolutely packed with
them as it paved the way for the likes
of John Wick to deploy a strategy of
non-stop action
while Japan China South Korea and the
United States have long been considered
the main sources of top quality action
the 2000s and 2010s have really seen an
uptick in other countries staking
significant claims that includes Germany
with 2016's Plan B in particular
providing the goods it's not surprising
that this movie really delivers on the
action once you realize that its top
build actors are stunt performers whose
work includes the likes of John Wick and
the matrix it's always nice when stunt
workers get the chance to actually be
themselves on screen the plot is fairly
standard as the protagonists need to
fight their way to rescue a friend from
gangsters but whatever it takes to get
these Fighters plowing through bad guys
is good enough IMDb has a plan C listed
as in development although there is not
much information about it available
elsewhere here's hoping though if you
only know Rizza as a member of the
Wu-Tang Clan or as a solo musician then
it's time to familiarize yourself with
his filmmaking considering his iconic
rap group's frequent references to
Classic Martial Arts Cinema it's hardly
surprising that he eventually got into
the game himself after spending some
time playing small roles and making
music for other action movies Rizza
finally went all in as a director for
2012's The Man with the Iron Fists it's
very much in the same vein as Quentin
Tarantino's genre tributes and though it
lacks some Polish and craft it still
proves to be an impressive debut with a
fun script co-written by fellow
Tarantino friend and collaborator Eli
Roth The Man with the Iron Fists is pure
camp and doesn't try to be anything else
it's a must-see for fans of the Wu-Tang
Rizza Tarantino and classic martial arts
they made me a
but if you help me
I'll Forge my greatest weapon ever
in addition to his time as an actor
South Korean filmmaker Rue San Juan has
proven to be an accomplished director in
his own right he tends to star in many
of his own films as he did for the
excellent 2006 martial arts Thriller the
City of Violence he plays you sequan one
of four men who have reunited on the
20th anniversary of their friend's death
an investigation into these still
unsolved murder then turns into a
violent quest for Revenge as suquan is
joined by his friend Jung tesu the men
basically become a two-man Army as they
kick punch and slice their way through
hordes of goons on their path to
Vengeance the action scenes are pulse
pounding and frequently funny which is
why someone has even been compared to
Quentin Tarantino
The Hitman films have pretty much locked
down their status as the definitive
version of the life of Bruce Lee's
teacher and mentor and it's hard to top
Donnie Yen as the title character but
those aren't the only times that his
story has ever been adapted for the big
screen in 2013 acclaimed Hong Kong
filmmaker Wang karwai went ahead and
offered his own take the Grand Master is
know it man and lead actor Tony Liang
chuwai can't quite compare to yet but
the Grand Master is still worth a look
as it takes a more philosophical and
introspective approach to Ip Man and the
world events that were occurring around
him in the 1930s and 40s but that's not
to say that there aren't plenty of great
fight scenes because there most
certainly are it's admittedly not quite
as good as any of the man films but the
Grand Master is a fine companion piece
to that series as it looks at the man
and his story in a slightly different
but equally interesting way any chance
that 2005's SPL Chapo Lang could have
been as big of a hit in the west as it
was in its native Hong Kong was severely
hamstrung when it was localized with the
generic title Kill Zone it's likely for
that reason alone that so many
English-speaking martial arts fans have
slept on this movie for those who missed
it you should know it's one of the best
action films of the century that it has
a killer cast that includes Donna Yen
and then it's directed by Wilson Yip of
it manfame the story involves a dying
Hong Kong detective who was trying to
get an Infamous Triad boss behind bars
as the last big accomplishment of his
career that mission is made a bit easier
by Ma Quan who's being trained to be the
detective's successor and is known for
his excessive use of force not only are
the fight scenes unsurprisingly
excellent considering the talent
involved but SPL is also extremely
compelling crime drama a follow-up
eventually arrived in the form of 2015's
spl2 a time for consequences it's a
sequel and name only though it's also
fantastic and well worth checking out
foreign
[Music]